he told me to follow the maze that it
would bring me joy but all I found is
pain and terror what motivated your
attack on Clementine
let's see jog your memory we've been
down this road before
you broke into my mind I built your mind
what else have you hidden from me
amazed isn't meant for you if you like
games so much why don't you try one who
loves Wyatt take me to her
you
hey youtubers it's Charlie so new
Westworld this is gonna be like a
combination of episode 9 trailer as well
as a breakdown of some of the theories
that episode 8 started to confirm like
that big twist so careful for spoilers
if you haven't seen episode 8 yet so the
show's doing something really cool it's
actually like slowly providing evidence
for a couple different theories at the
same time so you have William becoming
the man in black theory then you have
the three different timelines so if you
remember way back Ford
talked about him and Arnold living in
the park for five years before they
opened it to the public then they show
this clip of them dancing so when
Dolores reaches the secret town of the
spirit and starts happening the
hallucinations and asks which time am I
in you know extra bit of evidence that
she's seeing something that happened in
her past at that time and then in the
present-day storyline you have like the
old man in black who runs into the
service droid that greeted William when
he first entered the park and says oh
wow it's you again I would have thought
he'd decommissioned you by now I guess
he likes to keep a pretty face around so
the funny thing is is like you see her
in those two different places but you
also see her in Dolores as flashback to
the town that looks like that same time
period when Ford said that they were
first building the park before they let
people in like the 35 year ago timeline
so you have the three different
timelines with like this one girl
showing up in each different place I
can't believe they haven't
decommissioned you by now and then she
you know secretly turns out to be part
of Wyatt's gang but the other important
thing that they're teasing here is the
Wyatt storyline in present day he's like
this mystery uber villain to end all
villains but as we learned through this
writer storyline Ford has not chosen his
white yet he hasn't created him he's
like this character for which he built a
narrative but without actually building
the character so everybody is searching
for this mythical final boss and a
chapel that Dolores has been
hallucinating and it kind of looks like
the diorama on Ford's table here in the
previous episode so I think a lot of us
have come to the conclusion that Wyatt
is going to be Arnold in like Ford is
trying to engineer a scenario where
the part narrative helps him find Arnold
and get rid of him once and for all so
the show is kind of converging all of
its storylines as we reach the finale
but we know that it has a season two and
without saying who this is a bit of a
kicker there are a couple characters
that are part of these big storylines
that you think you know might end up
dying at the end of the season that have
already signed on for season two so you
kind of twist your head around but we
can talk about that when we get to the
finale it's kind of spoilery if you know
that people have signed on for season
two but the big thing right now is the
three different timelines how the man in
black became the man in black because
he's only just started to tease his
backstory he talks about his wife who
may have committed suicide because she
was so afraid of him for her tire life
meaning that if he really is William
then there was probably some event in
the past that made her think that he was
super evil so what a coincidence then at
the end of the episode
Logan rides up and tells Dolores and
William you're in deep [ __ ] now
so whatever ends up happening with Logan
at the end of the series that might be
the event that causes Williams wife to
think he was this terrible person inside
for his entire life despite never laying
a hand on his wife or his child so that
coupled with the mave realization that
the man in black you know engineered
this test for himself using this memory
that Maeve has been having this horrific
memory of losing her child just
completely blows your mind and it makes
you wonder what's gonna happen if Maeve
ever runs into the man in black because
now she has no problem killing humans
but just to go back to the Dolores
flashback where she know she sees
herself putting the gun at her head all
the dead bodies lying around does that
not look a lot like the Wyatt massacre
that Teddy was hallucinating earlier
when he was talking about his history
with Wyatt I just I like the way that
Ford has weaved Wyatt into his mind in
his history and we've never seen
Arnold's true face either and because of
what Ford says happened to Arnold what
might have happened in that five year
period before they opened the park like
the 35 year ago timeline is that Arnold
goes mad and helps bring about this
Massacre the way Teddy remembers Wyatt
massacring everyone
in this town so there are a couple big
revelations the show still has to make
like a couple confirmations we need
confirmation that the man in black is
really William we need confirmation that
Wyatt that the secret Wyatt that Ford is
coming up with is actually meant to be
the Arnold character in a jumping off
point for season two I know a lot of
people are wondering about the
Corporations plans that Tessa Thompson
has been trying to bring about which I
think we'll find out as a version of
immortality so they're currently
uploading all of the information of the
park into the cannibal hosts mind
remember the cannibal Abernathy who was
fond of quoting Shakespeare he seems
like he's getting ready for something
really special too so they're only two
more episodes so like they're really
gonna start getting crazy so if you're
behind be sure to catch up but I will be
doing videos for the rest of the series
be sure to subscribe to get those once
they finish I'll start doing a couple of
season 2 videos about things that I
think they'll be doing but they haven't
said too much about season 2 yet I think
they want to get through season one
before they start teasing storylines and
before the creators start saying hey you
know these are some of the big ideas
that we're gonna be following up on so
it's a great Maeve episode great episode
for revealing some clues for different
timelines so what's gonna happen next is
I'll post a Walking Dead trailer video
for the next episode and there's some
special stuff happening tonight on
Supergirl
if they do Cyborg Superman like I think
they will then I might do a video for
that later tonight too so there might be
three videos today but I'll be posting
updates on Twitter and Facebook so links
for all that stuff in the description
while you guys wait for that to post you
can click here for my other big
Westworld Theory video and you can click
here to learn all about Emilio Clark
from Game of Thrones joining the Star
Wars Han Solo movie thank you so much
for watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight